non aux eps teaser way bonjour monsieur
loïc bonjour monsieur fabre assez vous
un bel été tout à fait et vous donc bien
nous aussi on passe un bel été on est
très content de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui quand je me concentre plutôt
comme chacun sait ce qu'il dit quand on
va sur la casse tête à 2 j'ai reçu loïc
une petite boîte de casse tête comme on
en reçoit de temps en temps donc comme
les casse têtes de cons soit une boîte
tout net le hic une vie le bois tout net
secrète
ah oui on est sur quelque chose de léger
de discret à ses fans y tu peux
l'emmener avec toi en vacances que je
vous explique
il ya une boîte qui qui vend je crois
pas qu'ils en fabrique et vend des casse
têtes en france qui s'appelle insoluble
et ils m'ont envoyé sèches droites un
mode on a créé une énigme si tu veux la
résout pas donc voilà c'est pas un
partenariat c'est juste quand vous
m'envoyer des trucs que je les résout
rien non mais 6 mai
lorsque voire même à ceux qui sont pas
encore abonnés bon alors on a une grosse
boîte de la grosse boîte on a quoi on a
ce si joli une boule un support de
boules à pratiquer titre a clôturé pour
l'anniversaire je t'ai offert des petits
supports de bull s'est soulagé comme la
télé un radio réveil
merci n'y a pas de fil de patcher des
technopôles vous la radio mais un
triplex de theix une te vois pas de
blague non le mal un petit au monde un
mignon une petite enveloppe
c'est le sac dernier on en fait tu sur
des trucs un kop sa mère mais sans
déconner une l'après et voilà c'est tout
à fait voir il n'y a plus rien à
l'intérieur alors disposons nous
disposons ça sur la table dont des
toiles qui sortent en vrac à la dcri qui
sort le marc hé oui bon anna c'était pas
des chèvres tu vois alors on répertorie
un petit peu comme ça vous allez pouvoir
voir avec nous vous avez trouvé les
solutions avant nous ici on a un canada
à trois numéros boîte qui ne s'ouvrent
pas tu disais enfin tout cas pas au
premier abord une boîte sur support de
type avec des bouts d'excalibur dedans
ouais c'est clair des jean-michel bout
de bois ravaillac les textes un
parchemin bon on commence par lire la
lettre c'est ça bonjour fabien olicard
mois en vieil ami le maître des secrets
m'a beaucoup parlé de toi donc qui
s'occupait de tout ce qui est à toi tu
sais ce qu il prétend que ton temps est
infini et que tu n'en mettez de hectos
donc ton retour est infini tentant et
bateau est infini s'il te prétends que
ton temps est infini excellent livre
disponible à desservir l'est qui en
maîtrisent parfaitement ses rouages
depuis l'antiquité nous avons pour
mission de réunir tous les adeptes du
temps aujourd'hui nous souhaitons te
mettre à l'épreuve
au travers à travers mon ordre d'ali du
temps ne compte pas sur moi
pourtant c'est un peu agressif ne compte
pas sur moi pour télé un pas que ça à
[ __ ] compte pas sur moi pour tannique
et par quel chemin tu dois dormir seul
mais quel que soit le chantier que tu
choisi d'emprunter tu sais bien que si
chacun de départ et puis ou que le
précédent un moment donné tu vaincras
bien je te fais pas du tout ne t'attends
pas trouvé l'énigme linéaire avec des
points d'étape évident tu vaut bien
mieux que cela
mais je suis pas sur moi c'est ça a été
de me renvoyer toujours plus on croit
que c'est ça
peut-être que je vaux pas grand chose un
temps fabien on se souvient que tu
disais que tu l'aies le tueur de quel
âge as-tu les casse tête et du cou c'est
pour ça que je les prends je les regarde
pas ce que c'est ça non ça c'est la
preuve que chien tueur de quatre langues
au contraire les indices vogue au gré
des fluctuations de l'espace temps à toi
d'être subtil et en innovant en
distinguant les indications qui vont
permettre d'avancer sur le chemin de
celle qui te donneront des fragments du
code final te permettant d'ouvrir le
cadenas du tampon canalisant lot celui
ci bonne chance pour ce voyage magique
mon ami il est temps andromède guardian
du temps pour l'instant on sait pas on
sait qu'il va falloir taper un petit peu
dans tout et notre but ultime c'est de
trouver ces trois autres plats voici
[Musique]
mais vraiment tout mais ceux de leurs à
particules élémentaires et force de la
nature au lot au volant non je suis la
note d'accor et ben c'est bien c'est
bien tout ça mais clairement moi c'est
mon c'est mon point fort tout ce qui est
équations et type e ce qui me fait peur
c'est les chiffres 1,1 moi je sais pas
est ce qu'il faudrait voir les choses
récurrentes au niveau des couleurs on
est le 10 août on est le 10 août on est
le 10 août
est-ce qu'on tourne pas ça du tout avant
de prendre nos vacances ça du tout on
est maintenant on est on est revenu les
bretons et aux dix-huit chevaux
si tu veux te la jouer fine et je suis
un homme
on s'était déjà fait défaut de port
notre gros muscles bien sûr on peut en
avant des mois en voilà une langue des
bras un peu déformé grain mais c'était
trop jeune a 13 ans à 16 ans
bien sûr en voilà une autre celle ci
s'est quand même fait penser à un moment
je pense que tu veux un petit jeune bien
sympathique sébacées gentil merci fabien
le chat est en même temps mort et vivant
en gare non nous d'en savoir plus ça
c'est bien on en a assez
la brève histoire du temps d'un corps
des femmes bon moi je vais faire tout ce
qu elle boite l'espace et le temps a
peut-être qu'on trouvera une pile
quelque part selon ce que disent les
découvertes que j'ai fait cette boîte
oui j'en ai fait plusieurs d'accord la
première les amis c'est qu'ici on a deux
charnières ce qui ce qui nous
indiquerait que cette boîte s'ouvre
comme ceci la deuxième c'est que ce
petit livre la centrale ouais il bouge
il bougeotte chose qui se balade on a
quelque chose peut-être qu'à un bout de
bois rouaud un aimant qui suit un
couloir
ok on sait que ce n'est pas quelque
chose qui est libre parce que quand je
bouge comme ça que j'ai pas de bruit
c'est tout je ne sais pas grand chose
sur la boîte mais au moins j'ai c'est de
choses c'est un bon début et je vois
russe mans la boule web est maire il
faut qu'on ait quoi il a dit c'est pas
linéaire russie en août où la regarde
pas bien sûr les bouts d'eux des gens
michel des jean michel bolvin rss et du
coup et là on a une carte me disant
particules élémentaires et force de la
nature
et si j'ai notre vision de l'univers on
va peut-être venir les cartes parce que
regarde il y en a une autre on va
combiner à la fin un message on va on va
avoir un message avec ça bruno nouveau
message peut-être même regarde
podrabinek dessus je sais pas je n'en
mets tu suppute mais tu fais bien phase
d'exploration très bien très flou
a priori il faut faire sa logique tant
mieux faisant mieux
bonjour à holla holla c'était sur la
tranche
grâce au décalage
là j'ai pu lancer maintenant une
cleptomanie en fait je pense que la
vraie résolution
c'était à l'aca se poussent à mais grâce
à ça j'ai assez de poids pour faire ça
et après tout mais du coup je peux
bouger ça moi j'ai réuni ses pièces au
milieu je vous ai réunis ce soir pour
vous rassembler pour tu avais compris la
blague ou pas c'est quand même bizarre
qu'on puisse rien avancer sur cette
boîte même se saoule faut avancer là
dessus mais sa joie moi je pense pas
d'accord sur la trois cartes c'est que
en gros il faut dans la combien cocof
expo d-carte donc ça tant qu'on n'a pas
dix cartes et ben ça ah oui non mais moi
aussi je pense que là ça aurait pu me le
dire avant tout à l'heure il dit où il
est pas méchant en train de pousser au
une pile à temps y'a un truc le temps
être un grand m attention une fois de
déchiffrage amorcé tu en trouveras dans
les rouages du temps est une rancune
coach ans en fait dans la vie on a deux
solutions but c'est soit on fait ce qui
est attendu
soit on essaye de hacker la vie on va
essayer de la haac
beaucoup plus compliqué que ce que je
pensais que ce serait compliqué et si on
met le truc là dedans la sam est en
verve à chercher quoi je sais pas ça va
donner quelque chose je montre est parti
le à vos ça me rappelle un vieux truc de
scouts proposé pour les énigmes ont bien
à voter mais rendent écrivait à voter
c'est à voter dans l'urne tu vois et en
fait ça ça voulait dire que tu devrais
transformer son alphabet comme si la
lettre à c'était la lettre e ttc donné
la première lettre de l'alphabet eu la
deuxième latex texte donc je me dis si
associé à voter ou un avocat quelque
chose d'autre mais ça va être le même
principe il n'y a pas de deuxième rouge
que j'avais un peu
de booth
à voter on est clairement sur du
lave-auto voilà a appuyé la ce a voté à
voter on reste sur ce principe parle de
la beauté là bas que j'ai compris de
façon vous avez paraît cohérent petits
clous
ben dites le nous par voie postale
[Musique]
on a passé la phase ii on en a vraiment
ras le cul de ce casse-tête est vraiment
au score est ce que je pourrai enchaîner
un peu avec des casse tête à un peu plus
libérateur de joie de manière les
couleurs elles vont toutes du même côté
les symboles du même côté si on est
d'accord là dessus je
bien tu animes bien la vidéo de tu
penses qu'on l'attend à cons pour
combien de temps à une minute
ok bah je reviens dans une minute montre
un film
bah je pense parce que là comme
maintenant il ya le creux je vais
prendre le haut tout là haut ça fait une
heure qu'on est dessus
oui ils seront dix ans je dis oh oh je
déteste les castes et d'assemblage en
bois mais vraiment je vous le dis que
s'il ya un type de casse tête que je
déteste ces les assemblages en bois
comme ça de figure jamais je n'éprouve
aucun plaisir à les faire au match s
partager un même à travers des faire
sécher en mairie met à bas voilà bon
battant la famille j'ai vu qu'il y avait
une équation écrite et l'as bayonne à
des équations et crié 'toi celle-ci n
est pas ligne a tenté rester là dessus
mais ça me saoule
c'est pas d'âme on avait un truc est
écrit donc en gros ça non ça fait ça
marron je ne jouais cesson glossées lui
et celui-ci lycée bleu gris marron jaune
jaune marron bleu gris coq et la csa est
ce qu'on leur trouve quelque part là où
là on le retrouve précis mais si c'est
ça pourrait paraître dans l'autre sens
quoi mais voilà comme ça c'est en
mirepoix habana regarde là c'est bon
levier de ce côté là c'est bon parce que
tu es là c'est bon par contre - nakaya
retenir que ce côté là ce côté là je
pense que ça devrait être bon des deux
côtés et là on a une équation qui nous
fait 2 2 x y moins 5,2 entre park donc
précisons quand même pour ceux qui
savent pas de coller à une parenthèse
c'est comme s'il y avait un petit
multiplier invisible exhorte donc 2 x
entre parenthèses y moins 5
ben en fait ça ça doit être la formule 2
x et là on a des valeurs non mais si oui
là on est des valeurs pour y est
pourquoi je fais ça parce que comme il
ya 17 et demi on va faire des
multiplications par deux on va pu avoir
2 me après y moins 5
je cherche à résoudre x ok on dit y est
égal à quinze dans 15 - 5 ça fait 10 10
x 2 ça fait vingt
on
on vérifie les calculs 15 - 5 10 x 2
vingt sept et nîmois 5 2 ennemis fois de
5 11 et demi - 5 ça fait bien six et
demi si ça fait 13 13 - 5 sa faible
induit 8 x 2 5 à 16 4 ça fait de l'effet
demi la famille l'a fait 18ème disney ok
c'est bien qu'on ait ça et on n'oublie
pas qu'on a on a on avait tout à l'heure
il ya eu ça là à voter donc ça va bah si
c'est des lettres des alphabets à
s'amasser peu
et
c'est l'autre alors a priori ce ne sera
pas le bon code pour le clip tex ou pas
tu sais pas fait péter n'hésite t om psg
comme l'impression que ça souvent pas
bien donc il faut utiliser le à voter en
fait ça te fait un nouvel alphabet de la
manière suivante
donc si à voter assez comme ça
d'ailleurs que doré égal m
c'est à dire que le égale x
ça veut dire que le m égale fc a dû
changer gallas est mort et que le 19
non que le s égal elle est celle mxm ix
avec un max m x files
elle abat voilà en bas une fois qu'on va
dans la direction des flèches marché
bravo loïc c'est vraiment moi qui ai
tout fait alors bravo le lot merci
tintin au bout de ma vie inc là où j'ai
eu peur pour vous monsieur la gare là
presque assis un peu plus il est marqué
sur les étiquettes ou et cxl lb et ut
elle est ou non il y avait pas un moment
où c'est pas une énigme qua non mais
pour qu'on les gens de là où le voit
bien sur un petit zoom bruno tiens je
sais que tu es s'ils pouvaient nous
aider très oui oh oui oh oh tu des
boîtes en fait c'était même ça c'était
digne fallait la rentrée
avec un angle anguleux tu as titre de
titres
alors qu'est ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur
on a des trous noirs au haut et donc là
alors attendez il ya un texte à vue
ouais mec est à l'envers
ouais mais j'ai un miroir miroir miroir
aux sauveteurs en mer à l'horizon des
événements là où le temps est erratique
tu n'auras plus qu'un gars de temps sur
lequel s'appuyer ces garde-temps bas par
manche ressemble à un trou noir pas si
noir que cela lionheart ahaha
c'est ça s'était mal un singe m voilà ça
c'est lénine que j'aime et ce qui s'est
passé un trou noir un garde-temps sur
lequel tu n'auras qu'à t'appuyer
l'endroit où il ya plus de temps c'est
le trou noir
je me suis appuyé sur le temps donc
l'horloge et regardons lalalala feu dans
tes cachets on aime ça ça nous motive le
fer ce classico du festa président tu
voulais pas m'en aller
est ce que je veux le temps manquera
toutefois encore des papilles pip ppp ou
mail à ce qu'on aurait passé les
carrières damien est ce parce qu'on
n'aurait pas toutes les cartes en
infusion cartes sur table est ce que
n'aurait pas les cartes toutes les
cartes en main comme il y en a là y en a
5 2 3 mais ça aussi un seuil et un
boudin ah ben ça c'est pas les trois
chiffres nous et bat clermont c'est les
3 chiffres ma dent
voyons voyons ça d'abord alors voilà là
il y avait 1 2 3 4 5
le principe d'incertitude ça c'est le
cas je pense le chalet c'est facile
d'incertitude en fait que cha et en même
temps mort et vivant
gardons-nous d'en savoir plus
[Musique]
je suis le jumeau de cinq lots et le
couscous le croisé et cousines et
cousins la tap à inverser ces deux
cartes parfois et le gie le jumeau de 5
est le cousin de 11 et de trois suis-je
c'est pas plutôt genre le jumeau de 5
c'est peut-être deux fois simple par
exemple 5 11 et 3 ce sont des nombreuses
photos de moi c'est une photo de moi ça
c'est une photo de nous qui est la
greffe qui a l'art est dans les com
est-ce que je me suis coupé dans ton
idée 5 11 et 3 cd nombre de compromis
ok c'est quoi tous les nombreux pins du
moins donc c est pour qu on se donne une
idée c'est un 3 5 7 11 13 et c'était en
gros un nombre premier c'est un nom qui
n'est visible que par lui-même et
parlera donc là dans la séquence ils
montrent que cette ba ouais c'est ça
donc on dirait cette joute sain parce
qu'il est il à côté quoi ça va mal dans
ces cas-là trois seraient jumeaux de 5
aussi mais du coup cette île serait le
cousin du jumeau de 5 à force de tout
enrobé on n'est jamais sûr de nous quoi
battre d'accord et du coup si on a cet
ça nous aide en basse et ça donne un des
chefs du canada ouais mais là le coup ce
2 e s qui donnait ce qu'il faut faire
après il ya encore la petite étiquette
de sa mère arnaud art notamment une cx
lnb elle et ut alix wml rm a fait ces
annonces comme celle que tu sais le à
voter oui et là c'est un témoin
si tu veux c'est juste l'inversé de ce
qu'on a fait tout à l'heure mais comme
je l'avais écrit là on peut se retaper
vite fait
[Musique]
il
tu es octal du système octal en fait
comme on dit hexagonal pour la base 10
et décimales pour la vannerie salle doit
être la base du système au total donc
ces huit en fait on vient de choper 2007
le chiffre 8 avant qu'un et nous en
manque un qui doit être accessible par
s'agit de toute manière la lc il faut
connaître les trois décimales kiala et
ses cannes à ces indiqué comme ça tu
connais ça mais c'est fini ça tu connais
le web non mais ça c'est des décimales
de pi mais 22-11 1982 c'est un clin
d'oeil parce que c'est ma date de
naissance et ma date de naissance gelé
déjà cherché sur la tour de babel et 10
codes c'est après la 5000ème décimales
donc je connais pas ça le rend pas la
main dommage ça on l'a fait on l'a fait
c'est ce qui nous a donné huit donc
attendre on est d'accord qu'on a c'est
éviteront l'a eu
on le déduit de cette énigme là pour les
nombreux promeneurs et là il nous reste
ce que ça qui est pas utilisé c'est la
clé du temps nous a permis d'accéder au
chapitre est à présent la physique peut
être unifiée
je ne me rappelais de quelque chose tout
à l'heure mais un truc qui m'a frappé
l'oeil comme 7 m la wii la wii via un
chiffre tout seul seul tout comme ça
alors que lui fardeau qui a vécu et
écrit chapitre 10 lors de ses 5 derniers
chapitres louga 1
le punk ou pas ce que je pourrai dire à
mes amis mais ça c'est pas con parce
qu'il parle des chapitres restants de la
physique unifiée
allez on fait 7,1 ou 7 8 1 8 7
je donne l'ordre décroissant lors des
cross les matins ça ça nous fait je n'ai
pas envie de victoire c'est ça nous fait
là ça nous fait trois fois deux fois un
maxi possibilité de danser partie donc
si on a dit quoi achever 8,7 un aimable
j'en ferai pas d'autre personnellement à
ce que tu là t'as pas besoin bien malien
a été très choqué donc c'est parti c'est
le début de l'énigme sebha nouvelle
énigme au nom approprié encore des
caisses des deux combattants c'est la
fin au commencement naquit le temps peu
l'esprit ont su dompter et bien moi
encore l'apprivoiser j'ai pu juger de ta
bravoure de notre brave or le comité de
ta subtilités de la puissance de ton
raisonnement et de tes muscles v les
trois énigmes qui te font face sont le
symbole des défis qui attendent les
résoudre serait pourtant un jeu d'enfant
mais en saisir le sens ultime de prendre
à toute une vie bienvenue parmi nous
maître du temps félicitations ce trait
sur fort boyard mas papé
c'est ça est un outil dernier il a été
limité maître du temps et accord le 10
juin 2020 le fonds en avant ce cher sa
disparition dans le temps bah en fait il
reste que rien tant que ces pauvres
bon soit un débrief rapide est ce que
t'as kiffé alors j'ai kiffé sauf quand
il a fallu que tu montes ça en fait ça
ouais ça ça s'est même pas c'est
pourtant le feu ne s'est pas le faire
bolten ça pour le coup c'est un peu des
chaussettes sort un peu du du mou du
citepa jour en train de faire a alors
valoir la tête juste là point positif je
trouve c'est le storytelling point
positif c'est la qualité des accessoires
tu vois même là où s'était s'imposer et
qui est préréglé en plus pour ce n'est
tout ça je trouve ça cool
point négatif pour moi l'obligation
d'avoir une résolution de casse tête
géométrique parce que je déteste ça mais
je pense vraiment que je préfère lâcher
ouais mais que ça peut faire lâcher et
je dirais peut-être un peu trop de
difficulté je sais pas si ce truc qui
s'adresse à monsieur madame tout le
monde j'ai la boite sur leur site tu
vois mais peut-être un peu trop de
t du coup les nombreux problèmes ça donc
allé un peu trop et jamais
un peu trop interprétative non
l'alphabet à voter ça ma foi au macabre
est arrivé à oui oui c'est vrai que
j'aurais pas pensé après le fait qu'il
fait sur une semaine ouais mais les
jours sur une bosse on ne sait pas ce
que c'est un nombre premier raid avait
été va pas leur père et comme c'est un
stand quoi tu es vraiment un truc à
faire à plusieurs comme ça ça que tu
accumules des compétences et tout mais
c'était très cool bravo la solim le
casse tête merci à eux de nous avoir
envoyé ça je mets le lien vers l'un
celui dans la description ceci n'est pas
un partenariat c'est un remerciement qui
nous est envoyé ça s'est bien occupée et
c3 joli casse-tête qui nous offre eh
bien je vais les faire gagner ou ça sur
ton un style instagram les carences
inquiétantes
je vais gagner le cryptex sur mon
instagram donc n'hésitez pas vous pouvez
donc visiter leur site vous pouvez leaké
d'instagram de loïc suivre le mien
également abonnez vous à cette chaîne je
m'appelle toujours fabien olicard vous
abonner c'est gratuit activer la cloche
pour pas rater les prochaines vidéos
merci mon lolo d'avoir été là pour que
vous en grec mois merci merci à bientôt